Did you tidy up at all
before you got on national
television with me Beth?
Look at you.
(laughing)
Did you do any, did you think at all,
like I should probably maybe try
and straighten it up a little bit?
(laughing)
Did you give it any thought?
Look at this.
I got some, what do I got?
There's a shirt on a chair,
I have some laundry over in that corner.
Hey is that a-
And just to prove it, it does say-
Oh look at that.
"I love Conan."
That's, is that a heart or a butt?
It's a butt.
It looked like a butt to me.
That's actually a perfect
rendering of your butt.
You know what-
I memorized it.
that is what my, yes,
sadly, my wife will attest.
Drawn to scale.
You've seen my butt,
and that's about it. It's actual size.
(laughing)
I saw you have a cello,
Is that a cello you
have in the background?
Yeah.
You want me to... that's what I,
that's what I could have
put between you and taps.
A little,
(laughing)
a little ode to joy from me on there.
Yeah. Well, it's funny
because you haven't,
you're actually in a much nicer room
than I thought you were.
You just chose (indistinct).
(laughing)
You look fantastic, don't get
me wrong, you look lovely.
But the room is so much nicer.
You chose this, this terrible angle,
(laughing)
because you clearly don't
know what you're doing.
You are in the most depressing
corner of your house.
You know I usually have a...
here's a beautiful thing.
I usually have bean bag
chairs, but they're too hot.
They're too hot?
Yeah, it's too hot for a
bean bag chair right now.
Oh, I thought you meant like too sexy.
(laughing)
No.
I have bean bag chairs
but they're just too sexy.
It's just too sexy.
No one can handle it.
Look, you have a lovely place.
This is a fan.
Oh, that's your, yeah that's great.
Oh, look at you.
Go, you go.
(laughing)
This has turned into a tour.
Yeah.
I should have done this.
This is fantastic.
I should have gone right here.
That's fair, see,
everything we've seen is
much nicer than what you -
(bursts out laughing)
So I'm sorry, I'm just telling you.
Okay. Well we learned a lesson.
I think we did.
I'm going to change who I am.
Yeah.
No, no, just the room I'm in.
The fan. The fan is great by the way.
That fan is just killer.
Thank you.
That's the new look for you.
Just-
Thank you.
flowing.
Always wind blown.
Flowing.
You have that going for you
too, without even the fan.
I'm just going for this now.
I'm going to, it's pretty soon,
it's going to come straight down here
and I'm going to have to cut
out a little window right here.
That's what I'm going to do.
(Beth laughing)
Listen, I want to congratulate you again
on your hilarious special.
Thank you.
Really funny, and there's also-
Thank you for making it.
Well, you know-
I appreciate you.
I appreciate you being so
funny and being so talented
and Girl Daddy, look at that.
Look at the hat. HBO Max.
Watch it, please.
We'd love it if you watched it.
Yeah. Critics love it, it's great.
Yeah.
Twins.
Alright. I'll put mine on too.
And, We Called Your Mom podcast,
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.
That's right.
So keep on keeping busy.
I will.
Alright, thank you Beth. Bye.
Thank you.
Appreciate you.